[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the first ever
Friday
face of YouTube challenge with me Lottie
winter the beauty editor at lambing UK
and the amazing makeup artist Lisa
Potter Dixon hello I'm excited we have
to complete an amazing makeup look in
just 5 minutes we don't know what the
makeup occurs it's going to be a
surprise
we're about to find out five minutes
Oh Gaga at the Met Ball right there's
incredible lashes in five minutes Lottie
I'm screwed there's not just any old
lashes as like lashes at those gems
those liner this lipstick there's a hat
do we have a hat I mean I think the main
focus is the white liner that's gonna be
important because that's what makes the
eye shape and then just sticking on
lower lashes and a bit of pink lip okay
whatever we can do maybe just one I go
okay I've got everything going on there
is also I'm starting already go five
minutes you're joking
come on okay we've got I mean honestly
lashes alone for five minutes so we've
got black liners we've got white liners
we've got the pink for the lipstick so
basically got everything we need and
it's just now what eating first I'm
putting on both lashes my god I love how
we're approaching this so different so
differently oh my god one always goes on
well and then the other one doesn't put
enough glue on this one okay
yeah made a mess already honestly I'm
like this and the white is very
unpredictable because it's quite um
liquidy are using a 21 yeah I'm using
this I'm changing now to a Mac like face
paint I just think I can get more
precision to that we should go oh oh
dropped it down me Oh also he's got to
make sure we have time for the pink list
because I feel that that brings it all
together definitely that's gonna be me
that's what makes it forget what we're
doing right now is all about
I've even got the gold lash I've lost my
glue where's the glue I've got to move
on I spent too long wait I'm cutting my
losses and chucking a few gems on oh
yeah I love that some Joker's put pretty
sick on the table as if like they know
we're going to run out of time I think
we're gonna need it yeah yeah put on
this that was right at the beginning I'm
covered in glitter which is a usual day
for me to be honest don't baby love
because my lashes are gonna fall look
this is gonna look awful I feel like I'm
some sort of creature don't forget you
think I haven't even done the white on
the top the lashes we're gonna do one
more thing quick I'm only doing one eye
okay I'm nearly done no I'm not stopping
done yeah Wow
I'm not gonna say for my best work have
you done both eyes ready ready yeah go
on exactly the same yours looks so much
better houses better this is a vibe look
at that the one eye over as well no I
think it's coming else's nose you got
lipstick on your teeth but don't worry
about that thank you so much for
watching at the first ever Friday face
off YouTube challenge I really hope you
enjoyed it and don't forget to like
subscribe comment also we challenging
you mm-hmm good luck ok this very look
in five minutes and don't forget to
hashtag hashtag Friday face-off and at
glamor UK so we can check all your
amazing looks out and
most importantly hmm who do you think
won today me Olli I just chucked it all
on my face and hope for the best
opener all winners good luck quitting
yours guys yeah good luck and see you
next time bye